hello everyone and welcome to Thermo
Fisher Scientific webinar series on
protein and cell analysis education
today we present on high content
screening based phenotypic analysis of
organo tipic 3d bronchial tissues
presented by dr. Diego Maura Scotty a
high content screening manager of system
toxicology at Phillip Morris
International Rd I'm Suzy Valdez and
I'll be your moderator for today's
educational webinar presented by lab
routes and sponsored by thermo Fisher
Scientific before we begin I'd like to
remind everyone that this event is
interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want at any time you
want during the presentation you can
submit them in the question box located
on the left hand side of the screen
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for at the end of the
presentation
also please notice that you'll be
viewing the presentation in a slide
window to enlarge the window just click
on the screen icon located on the top
right if you have any trouble hearing or
seeing the presentation click on the
support tab located at the up above the
slide window or use that question box on
the left and let us know you're having a
problem I'd now like to introduce
today's speaker dr. Diego Maura Scotty
dr. Maura Scotty is a high content
screening manager in the systems
toxicology department at Philip Morris
International our MD after completing
his PhD in oncology and a molecular
pharmacology at the University of
Ferrara he continued his research
investigating the mechanism of tumour
escape from immune surveillance as a
scientist he joins Philip Morris
International in 2012 bringing his
knowledge and interest for flow
cytometry and imaging he is now leading
a team of researchers which operate a
high-throughput system for compound
profiling please join me in welcoming
dr. Maurer Scotty I will now turn the
presentation over to him welcome sir
very much for the kind introduction and
please let me sanctum a scientific for
giving me the opportunity to talk and
describe the work that here at Philip
Morris we are doing so to set the
context of today's topic we need to
refer to the three heart principles
which were developed more than 50 years
ago and is based on the concept of
replacement reduction and refinement of
animal use in science in scientific
field such as toxicology where harmful
substances are tested for evaluating the
potency of their effect 3r
implementation as in the last ten year
became a major objective several
international agency have developed a
joint program known as sin 21st century
toxicology with the scope of developing
more efficient and less time-consuming
approaches to predict toxicity in this
context that Philip Morris International
with a view to the scope of 21st century
technology strategy a system toxicology
based approach has been established as a
part of the ongoing assessment of the
reduce risk product product with a
potential to reduce individual risk and
population harm in comparison to
conventional cigarette system toxicology
is a branch of science which residues at
the intersection of system biology and
toxicology it integrates classic
toxicology 12 approach with
computational network models in
quantitative measurement of molecular
and functional changes occurring across
multiple level of biological
organization it is therefore a
multidisciplinary approach which
combines principle of chemistry computer
science mathematics and physics with
high content experimental data with the
scope of characterizing and evaluating
interaction between potential hazard and
the components of a given biological
system omics technologies in combination
with advanced high content screening
method represent the fundamental pillar
of a system toxicology based approach
this technology not only help to
understand mechanism of toxicity and
disease processes but they also
facilitate application in line with the
vision of the three horse
in fact the strategy recommends the use
of more physiological in vitro model
which in combination with computational
models could accomplish the prediction
of in vivo effect based on in vitro data
here at Philip Morris International we
routinely use to disinterred cell
culture system together with a series of
image based Han points which
individually or multiplex are used to
characterize toxicity profile of various
compound and product of interest the
table on the Left show a summary of view
of Han point that are included in our
routine toxicity profiling markers of
oxidative stress mitochondrial health
self I ability and cell cycle related
markers are most commonly investigated
relying on the use of lung and
cardiovascular in vitro model such as
normal human bronchial epithelial cells
in human coronary heart you can do till
yourself the panel of image on the right
shows example of some of the is in point
in particular representative images of
untreated and positive control treated
including phosphorylation of Easton to a
X location of nuclear factor KB and
increase in certain and and an ability
are shown for many decades under
submerged to the culture represented the
only available tool for scientist the
requirement for more physiologically
relevant in vitro system rosalie
mimicking the characteristic and
functionality of the part of the human
body de model has led to development of
more complex cellular model which range
from 2d Co culture to 3d composter
culture system it is widely accepted and
recognized the 3d cell culture system
enable a more accurate in physiological
representation of the in vivo
environment allowing for intercellular
interaction with more realistic
biochemical and physiological responses
today 3d model are widely used for
different application and are also part
of our in vitro model portfolio however
the increasing complexity of this model
has also introduced several new
technical challenges which I will
introduce in the remaining parts of the
presentation to further evolve our AI
content screening assay portfolio and
leverage the work performing 2d model we
invested in the development of imaging
based approaches which would enable eye
content investigation of 3d bronchial
tissues when grown to confluence on a
transverse system and culture at the air
liquid interface normal human bronchial
epithelial cells form a polarized filter
stratified epithelia composed of basal
ciliated and goblet cells this culture
system provides a useful tool for the in
vitro study of airway epithelial biology
as a cloner model the architecture and
the micro environment found in in vivo
situation when compared to submerge
cells in vitro response of
differentiated re epithelial cells may
more accurately model the lung response
as a proof of concept we decided to
investigate phenotypic markers which are
known to characterize the 3d model of
the human hyper hard way in particular
cell type specific markers such as beta
tubulin using 5 AC and p53 were selected
to identify ciliated goblet and bizarre
cells respectively in addition the one a
member of the family of the tight
Junction protein was also included
imagine the 3d model meant we had to
overcome some technical challenging
arising from the intrinsic physical
properties of the cellular model
first of all with intention to avoid any
additional manipulation of the hint set
we would have made the process more
time-consuming and labor-intensive the
intent insert including the triangle
holder add to the image this is of
course two direct implication first
along as the incidence between the cells
and the camera objective and second the
presence of a micro porous membrane both
actor mains are interfere with the
imaging process potentially leading to
decrease and less sharp signal detection
in addition 3d Ally models are more
complex cellular morphology is in fact
no longer comparable to the 2d
counterpart because of the added third
dimension as a consequence we are
looking at a much more pronounced
cross-section of the model and also at
an even spatial distribution of the
nuclei RIE compton screening based
method the 2d cell culture nuclear
staining is normally used as a reference
for focal plane and for cell
identification unfortunately this
approach proved to be challenging when
applied to more complex 3d culture in
fact as just mentioned the an even
spatial distribution of the nuclei is
impacting both in image focus and also
the identification of the individual
nuclei to overcome these technical
issues the standard image analysis
workflow had to be reconsider the he
moves into account that now the
scientific investigation could be per
for both a cellular and tissue level
depending on the scientific question
single cell selection may also not be
relevant in the context of the 3d
culture as it could be more interesting
to perform the evaluation of the entire
tissue structure furthermore we notice
that unlike nuclei the special
distribution of the selected markets
along the z-axis appear to be more
consistent therefore we decided to
utilize the selected phenotypic markers
to identify the optimal focal plane for
their imaging
it's just magnificent the identification
of a unique and consistent focal plane
based on nuclear staining was
challenging and it often led to a
failure as the instrument was enabled to
identify the focal plane to enable a
more consistent and reliable detection
each of the selected phenotypic market
which showed a more consistent spatial
distribution along the z-axis was use as
a reference to identify the optimal
focal plane for the imaging once this
was determined a specific offset was
then applied to image the nuclear
counterpart
as previously anticipated since we were
not interested in single cell
identification but rather in evaluating
and characterizing the wolf structure of
the tissue the nuclear staining was
analyzed using the Spock detection
method a rapid and flexible image
analysis algorithm that can be utilized
to provide generic spot analysis
applicable to a variety of AI content
assay normally use for identification
and analysis of intracellular pull tight
objects such as multi-protein complexes
specialized and ozone or other
organelles it is in this case use for
tissue component identification this way
we could evaluate how big an area of the
field of view was effectively covered by
the tissue it was in fact possible to
identify those field
where the tissue is damaged or detach as
well as those were the camera reach the
border of the insert by simply
evaluating the total spot area at field
of view level the method robustness was
evaluated by have arranged the values of
for inter field of view from for
independent replicate as shown by
standard deviation variation was shown
by the standard deviation variation was
minimal similar to detecting the nuclear
signal the expression of the Pacific's a
no tipping marker was investigated by
applying a spot detection based mask in
this example on the image on the left
you can see the classical tight Junction
signal following the one staining this
very much looks like an image obtained
with normal bronchial epithelial cells
grown at two congruence this image also
shows the typical cuboidal shape of the
cells which they acquire when
differentiated at re in the center and
in the right image we have example of
stain ciliated Engelbert cells
respectively it can be very well
appreciated how OMA geniusly distributed
these cells types are across the walls
fail
one of the advantages of AI content
imaging similar to other fluorescence
based method is the possibility to
investigate several markers
simultaneously in this example basil and
goblet cells are stained in the same
tissue p53 the bath of cell markers is
imagining the green channel while new
since I've a see a market of goblet
cells image in the file read such a
combination enables gathering biological
insight while decreasing cost as both
markers can be investigated
simultaneously in the same tissue
however the approach is of course
limited by reagents have ability
florican wave wavelength and antibody
species compatibility must be in fact
considered when the staining protocol is
designed
as people it mentioned it was our
intention to also evaluate the world
structure of the tissue beside the spot
detection based numerical quantification
of the qiat cellular feature the single
field of view images taken with both
fluorescence and brightfield microscope
can also be mounted to enable wool
tissue visualization after accurate
optimization of the form factor it is
possible to fully image the entire 3d
tissue by taking 60 images with a 10x
focus the visualization of this image is
proven to be very valuable in the
valuation of the world tissue structure
in fact structural damage at
abnormalities can be easily spotted
whether for a higher throughput and
time-saving applications such as
fine-tuned quantification of the marker
of interest it may be sufficient
limiting the investigation to 16 or 32
field of view as they will already
represent 35 and 70% of the world tissue
area respectively with the project
described so far I contend imaging can
be used to evaluate more complex 3d in
vitro model for example it can be
exploited as a tool for fast and
accurate quality control of the tissue
it is in fact possible within 24 hours
to evaluate both the expression and the
distribution of tissue maturation marker
in addition the very same markers can
also be used as a Sperry mental endpoint
in experiment looking at specific
phenotypic changes such as complex
algebra pleasure or the loss of buyer
integrity in the next couple of light I
will now introduce you to example where
this approach will use
with regard to the tissue quality
control will Everly perform evaluation
of phenotypic marker expression and
distribution once maturation is achieved
in the example reported in this slide
expression of Celia is evaluated by
imaging the world tissue upon staining
with auntie beta-tubulin for it can be
very well noted that the expression of
the marker is not homogeneous in fact
the tissue is characterized by a higher
expression of the market in the outer
ring compared to the center this was
further confirmed once the image was
analyzed with the spoke detection
algorithm extrapolation of the data at
field of view level enable a
quantitative comparison between the
outer ring and the center of the tissue
the next example is instead focus on an
in vitro model of goblet cellular
pleasure which was evaluated as a proof
of concept as th type 2 site against
such as il-13 was previously
demonstrated to induce a gobbet cell
hyperplasia phenotype in the airway
epithelium in vivo we decided to
evaluate if the same phenotype could be
recreated in vitro using our 3d Brown
Calcasieu
il-13 was applied apically in a repeated
session and an evaluation of the
phenotype was performed using the
approach of staining goblet cells with
using a fi fi v v AC specific antibody
as described before using our
development method we demonstrated the
tile 13 induce an almost four-fold
increase in global sales density as
shown by the total area of the spot
detection in addition looking at the
average intensity we also noted an
increase of nearly 40 percent of mock v
AC production at single cellular level
altogether this data showed that
combining a content screening based
application with more complex in vitro
culture which better resemble the in
vivo physiology represent a step forward
in the process of in-vitro method
development aim to enable the
replacement of the use of animals in
research
an additional step aim to increase the
biological investigation at sample level
is the combination of high content
screening method together with
traditional immunised Oh chemistry I
condom screening allows a planar
characterization of the tissue by
providing information with regard to the
x and y axes these information are very
valuable as they can describe the
distribution of different cell types
through the world tissue providing
evidence of this organization on the
other end in bonito chemistry instead
providing a longitudal view of the 3-d
structure along the z axis and therefore
are useful to visualize and investigate
cell polarization and then development
of the tissue in the third dimension
combination of the two methods applied
on the very same sample will provide a
more comprehensive morphological
characterization of the tissue
architecture and will enable a more
accurate analysis of maturation process
all imaging process and analysis
performing this presentation were
performed with thermo scientific cell
inside six seven which compared to
previous model such as IRIScan VT I as a
superior flexibility in terms of
focusing option and available wavelength
the integrated confocal module has
improved performance shorter exposure
time more even images and overall better
calm focal image quality color bright
field LED also offer more option for
acquiring picture in the Bryce's
spectrum overall 67 proved to be more
flexible and more robust than the
modular horizon
the presented work was develop and
perform in the system toxicology
cellular laboratory of the research and
development center of Philip Morris
International in OSHA tells its an
especial a special thank goes to all the
contributors who have supported help
developing and perform the study
Thank You dr. Maura Scotty for that
informative presentation we will now
start the live Q&A portion of our
webinar if you have any questions you'd
like to ask please do so now we'll
answer as many questions as we have time
for so let's begin and take a look at
our audience questions dr. Maura Scotty
you show that the nuclei are not
identified and selected as singular and
independent objectives but rather
analyzed considering the area they cover
could you better explain how then the
object normally intended as single cells
is defined in your process sure to be
honest object identification is actually
not a form as classically done when
working with 2d cell remodel in fact the
algorithm is set in a way that the
entire field view isn't is identify as
an object and then in cell count is not
consider we rather intend to evaluate
the tissue integrity if you put this
into the context of peurto psychological
assessment you wish to do the classical
send count as cell viability readout you
will find this approach extremely
complicated when toxicity is I the
tissue will detach no imaging will be
possible in this case the biological
system has some limitation as only sub
toxic concentration should be tested to
still ensure a reliable readout
thank you and I want to thank our
audience for their live participation
this next question has two parts dr.
Maura Scotty the instrument used for the
images acquisition is equipped with a
confocal module did you test it in the
context of this analysis and if yes what
could be the advantages
in the presented work we did not include
any confocal image however we did have
tested and evaluated the use of the
confocal module with this tissue but we
found no particular benefit in the
contest of the presented approaches
surely it can be of help if different
hand points and analysis would be
considered I could for example imaging
that investigation of nuclear factor
translocation would definitely require
such an approach by using confocal
microscopy thank you our next question
considering the increased complexity of
the 3d tissues when compared to standard
2d submerged cells could you comment on
how the staining procedure was adapted
to the cellular module
overall the entire staining process do
not really differ much from the 2d
procedure we simply that the sum of the
step in particularly antibody delusion
and incubation we still perform a pretty
standard and fixation incubation time of
about 20 minutes and then
permeabilization as blocking is
performed for about an hour and primary
antibody is incubated overnight to
ensure that it can penetrate and reach
also the bottom part of the of the
tissue in case the secondary antibody
views that is then headed for an
additional hour usually the staining
procedure is performed only at the
apical side in order to use only little
amount of the reagent about hundred
micro litre in total that is the volume
that we regularly spike on top of the of
the of the tissue however depending on
the thickness the tissue sometimes
develop it might be sometimes necessary
to perform additional staining from the
basolateral side
thank you and I want to remind audience
members that any questions not answered
today will be answered via email dr.
Maura Scotty I want to give you some
time to just provide any closing remarks
for our audience members I want to thank
again some official Scientifics for the
opportunity for showing the work that
here at Philip Morris has been done the
past few months and here it's an ongoing
process and I really hope to get another
opportunity later to to show follow-ups
of the of the young going i content
connectivity and the development of new
cellular model that we are enrolling for
in vitro assessment
and thank you again sir for your
informative presentation and for your
important research I'd also like to
thank lab roots and our sponsor Thermo
Fisher Scientific for making today's
educational webcast possible before we
go I want to remind everyone that
today's webcast will be available for
on-demand viewing 2018 you'll receive an
email from lab roots letting you know
that this webcast will be available for
replay please share that announcement
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event that's all for now
and thank you for joining us we hope to
see you again soon goodbye